[Musique]
bonjour à tous bonjour à tous et
bienvenue dans auditions publiques
l'émission politique commune à LCP et
publique Sénat dans l'actualité de ce
lundi 10 octobre en la déclaration des
manuels Macron aujourd'hui en réaction à
la grève dans les raffineries qui
provoquent des embouteillages monstres
dans les stations le blocage n'est pas
une façon de négocier a-t-il dit entre
autres c'est un dossier chaud pour le
gouvernement qui entre aussi aujourd'hui
dans le vif du sujet avec l'examen de
budget à l'Assemblée donc la macronie
s'attend à des combats très musclés
bonjour à robergé merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous vous êtes la présidente du
groupe Renaissance à l'Assemblée
nationale votre job est d'éviter autant
que possible les quoique dans votre
groupe et de trouver des alliés on vous
dit adeptes des coûts vous vous êtes
fait remarquer la semaine dernière par
votre interpellation énergique sur les
violences sexuelles les violences
conjugales ça a été saluées
chaleureusement par la majorité très peu
apprécié par la nups vous assumez la
confrontation directe avec elle et fille
mais fallait-il électriser ce débat
alors que les Français sont en but à des
difficultés matérielles liées à
l'inflation est-ce la bonne méthode
aussi pour ménager les chances de
concertation avec l'opposition selon
vous le 49-3 sera provoqué par
l'opposition s honnête de reporter la
faute sur vos adversaires politiques
Brigitte boucher et Steve Jourdain vont
revenir entre autres sur le débat à
venir dans l'hémicycle Yves Thréard vous
interrogera sur la stratégie politique
de la majorité Vincent roux vous posera
des questions d'actualité et puis vous
débattrez vous avez accepté on vous en
remercie avec la députée Europe Écologie
Les Verts et Vassas qui poussera une de
ses propositions un ISF climatique
pourquoi pas mais d'abord je voudrais
revenir avec vous sur ces embouteillages
qui sont les images pour les Français
les plus marquants de leur vie
quotidienne dans les stations d'essence
des embouteillages provoqués par des
grèves dans les raffinerie voilà ce
qu'on a dit entre autres Emmanuel Macron
tout à l'heure le gouvernement prend sa
part en mettant la pression pour que les
négociations aboutissent au plus vite
mais faut que les parties prenantes
prennent leur responsabilités les
entreprises et les chefs d'entreprise
concernées et les syndicats concernés le
blocage c'est pas une façon de négocier
le blocage n'est pas une façon de
négocier les salariés qui font grève ont
tort de vouloir provoquer une une
avancée des négociations avec Total par
exemple le point de départ c'est en
effet des profits exceptionnels qui ont
été réalisés par total 6 milliards
d'euros sur un trimestre mais c'est
aussi des négociations qui sont déjà
intervenus au sein de l'entreprise qui
ont permis des augmentations de salaire
de 3,5% pour un niveau de revenus moyens
de 5000 euros par mois c'est ça dont on
parle quand même moi ce que je constate
c'est quoi c'est qu'aujourd'hui dans nos
territoires ceux qui en pâtissent ce
sont ceux qui veulent aller travailler
ce sont nos aides à domicile ce sont nos
infirmières sont nos chauffeurs taxis
qui sont oblig de faire plusieurs
stations services pour espérer pouvoir
travailler parce qu'ils n'ont pas
d'autre choix que d'utiliser leur
voiture donc bloquer c'est aujourd'hui
bloquer ceux qui travaillent et ceux qui
doivent pouvoir librement travailler
nous notre responsabilité c'est quoi ça
a été d'abord de faire baisser les prix
c'est ce qu'on nous a demandé parce que
le premier risque qu'on avait sur le
carburant c'était des prix trop élevés
qui sait qu'il y avait des Français qui
n'avaient plus les moyens là encore de
pouvoir circuler librement deuxième
responsabilité c'est quoi c'est s'il le
faut réquisitionner si on doit
réquisitionner pour garantir un moment
des approvisionnements notamment sur des
métiers qui sont essentiels c'est de
libérer des stocks stratégiques de
l'État on l'a fait je pense notamment
aux transports scolaires on peut pas
accepter que nos enfants puissent plus
aller à l'école après oui les
négociations mais c'est négociations
elles peuvent pas en permanence se faire
sous la contrainte et sous le blocage
alors qu'on a d'autres organisations
syndicales qui elles justement ne
prennent pas cette voie là ne sont pas
là pour faire le blocage parce que
Laurent Berger appelle la grève
préventive mais accepte d'être dans un
vrai registre de négociation et de
dialogue alors la grève préventive on y
reviendra mais tout de même ce que vous
dites là c'est très bien voilà ce qu'on
fait entreprendre la responsabilités on
a l'impression que une fois encore le
gouvernement est en retard et qu'il
monte dans le train un peu tardivement
qu'il court derrière les événements et
diabète borne est monté au créneau hier
Emmanuel Macron aujourd'hui on a très
peu entendu les ministres fin de semaine
dernière on était déjà dans une
situation locale est-ce que très
honnêtement il n'y a pas eu un peu de
retard à l'allumage mais on a eu
franchement un déblocage de situations
dès la fin de semaine dernière c'est à
dire que la libération des stocks
stratégiques notamment dans des régions
qui étaient très entravées je pense aux
hauts de France c'est dès la fin de la
semaine dernière le fait que les camions
puissent approvisionner tout au long du
week-end y compris le dimanche
c'est des trucs ne calme pas la panique
des automobilistes j'entends
complètement la panique et je comprends
évidemment que celles et ceux qui ont
peur que dans quelques jours ils ne
puissent plus rouler parce que ils ont
un plan qui progressivement maintenant
est à 50% 30% se disent je dois y aller
le plus tôt possible je comprends le
réflexe évidemment des Français ce qu'on
doit faire nous c'est faire en sorte de
réguler pour que grâce à cela cette
semaine les choses reprennent leur cours
de manière normale
et en travaux le point de départ c'est
pas le gouvernement le point de départ
c'est déblocage lié à un syndicat la CGT
dans une entreprise parce que dans
d'autres entreprises on a des
négociations et ceux par exemple son a
négociation qui avance donc l'entreprise
totale donc oui il faut que les
négociations reprennent mais la
négociation ne peut pas être en
permanence sous la contrainte du blocage
et de la garde mais Aurore berger guerre
préventive notre invité la semaine
prochaine ce sera Laurent Berger donc
c'est lui qui a lancé vous dites je suis
d'accord avec être prévente une grève
préventive mais enfin une grève si vous
voulez un posteriorer ça n'a pas
beaucoup de sens une greffe préventive
en Allemagne il y en a il y en a c'est
la règle donc quel problème il y a un
moment d'abord on discute si on voit
qu'il y a des points de crispation et
qu'on n'arrive pas par la négociation
avancer alors on utilise la greffe comme
dernier recours et comme levier de
pression là avant même les négociations
alors qu'on a une entreprise et je ne
dis pas qu'elle ne doit pas faire des
efforts encore une fois 6 milliards
d'euros de bénéfices etc sur entre
calendrier de négociation on doit faire
des efforts donc je dis pas le contraire
spontanément mais encore une fois on
n'est pas sur une entreprise qui a
refusé toute augmentation de salaire
elle l'a rappelé trois virgule 5%
d'augmentation et une prime
d'intéressement ou en moyenne je crois
que les salariés ont bénéfié de 7000
euros l'anglais les demander salariés
sont abusées non mais c'est ça fait deux
fois vous insistez sur le niveau de
rémunération parce que je pense que
c'est important un moment de savoir
quelles sont les publics concernés et de
savoir encore une fois celles et ceux
qui sont bloqués aujourd'hui et celles
et ceux qui sont bloquées n'ont des
facto pas souvent les niveaux de
rémunération qui existent dans les
raffineries et je pense qu'il faut avoir
aussi l'honnêteté de le dire et
l'honnêteté de dire qu'à un moment on ne
peut pas faire payer le prix fort à
celles et ceux qui aujourd'hui et bien
s’angoissent en effet quel est
l'objectif du gouvernement doit vous
penser que la situation doit être revenu
à la normale quand évidemment dès cette
semaine ça doit être l'objectif qu'on
doit vendredi c'est dès cette semaine
que ça doit revenir à la normale les
approvisionnements comptaient
normalement doivent concourir à cet
objectif-là la première ministre réunit
ce soir des sons d'Algérie les ministres
qui sont directement concernés
de manière justement à avancer et encore
une fois il y a pas de sujet tabou s'il
faut réquisitionner on réquisitionnera
s'il faut faire en sorte aussi que des
stations services soient dédiées à des
personnels spécifiques je pense par
exemple à la question des soignants et
bien évidemment on le fera alors les
réquisitions précisément on va peut-être
en reparler d'ailleurs bonjour Brigitte
boucher Steve Jourdain
c'est à vous oui prête 30 stations
essence qui sont touchées par cette
grève donc des réquisitions vous vous
dites pourquoi pas c'est ça oui je dis
pourquoi pas parce qu'encore une fois on
peut pas accepter qu'il y ait des
Français qui soient empêchés de circuler
évidemment mais surtout d'aller
travailler ce soir ça pourrait être en
effet décidé c'est la raison pour
laquelle après un ministre elle réunit
dès ce soir les ministres qui sont
concernés c'est la raison pour laquelle
elle a appelé manière très nette et très
claire à la négociation et qu'en effet
le président a rappelé aussi un
prérequis qui me paraît important
démocratie qui est de dire que c'est pas
d'abord le blocage c'est d'abord la
négociation et la concertation qui
doivent prévaloir envoyer l'armée pour
débloquer les raffineries Xavier
Bertrand a dit pourquoi pas c'est pas
totalement exclu vous vous dites quoi je
sais pas s'il faut en venir à envoyer
l'armée puis bon j'entends l'image un
peu spectaculaire que ça renvoie
l'objectif il est pas là l'objectif
c'est qu'à un moment si on doit pouvoir
réquisitionner parce qu'on est presque
sur une j'allais dire comme une
obligation de service public parce qu'à
un moment les Français n'ont pas d'autre
choix que de pouvoir être dans une
station-service pour pouvoir faire leur
plein donc on a besoin de cette
continuité d'approvisionnement donc
encore une fois la première je pense
qu'elle prendra la décision qui
s'imposent dès ce soir et je le dis
clairement s'il faut réquisitionner des
dépôts ce sera fait s'il faut
réactionner aussi des stations de
service pour garantir
l'approvisionnement de professions pour
la santé pour les cars scolaires pour
les gars scolaires pour nos pompiers
pour la sécurité de notre pays tout
simplement on a des missions qui peuvent
pas s'arrêter ça c'est le cas dans les
Hauts-de-France ça pourrait s'étendre à
l'ensemble de la France pourrait
s'étendre là où il y a des sujets on a
des régions qui aujourd'hui qu'il
faudrait pas qu'on crée nous-mêmes un
ventre de stress ou de panique il ferait
que dans des régions où il y a aucune
raison qu'elle soit touchée tout d'un
coup l'angoisse génère elle un risque de
pénurie alors il y a ce risque de
pénurie il y a des gens qui remplissent
leur bidon pour l'interdire ça oui je
crois que là dessus il faut être très
clair c'est à dire qu'à un moment on
n'arrive pas dans une station-service
pour faire son plein et puis pour
remplir
certains préfèrent la liberté de chacun
s'il a besoin d'un jerrican de le faire
comme on voulait l'interdire certains
préfèlent ont mis en place directement
dans les départements c'est aussi une
question à un moment de de bon sens de
responsabilité individuelle en avance un
peu comme on a vu sur certains produits
essentiels au tout début de la crise
covid vous voyez bien que c'est parfois
le stress qui est totalement légitime
mais qui peut provoquer des pénuries qui
normalement ne doivent pas pouvoir
exister
la défense de total c'est notamment de
publier les mesures sociales qui ont été
prises par l'entreprise en 2022 on
apprend que la rémunération moyenne d'un
opérateur de raffinerie et de 5000 euros
brut par mois participation compris
c'est des chiffres qui ont été contestés
par les syndicats peut-être sur la
méthode est-ce que vous approuvez cette
méthode de faire de la part de Total
les rémunérations comme ça publiquement
la vérité c'est contesté encore une fois
par les syndicats mais j'imagine que
dans ces cas-là il sortiront les
chiffres est-ce que ça doit être affiché
comme ça en public mais je vois pas où
est la difficulté à un moment de faire
de la transparence ou c'est nous on nous
demande en permanence qui est de la
transparence qui puisse exister je vois
pas pourquoi à l'intérieur des
entreprises ça pourrait pas être fait
sur d'autant plus quand on a et
l'intention vous comprenez bien la
question de Steve c'est que l'intention
totale c'est de dire ils sont déjà mieux
payés que largement mieux payés que les
Français sont en France à l'ère médian
c'est important de savoir sur cette base
un moment les négociations peuvent
exister et que tout simplement les
Français de savoir quels sont les
revendications d'un côté et j'ai
commencé mon propos en disant que les
revendications évidemment d'augmentation
de rémunération dans un période de
bénéfice exceptionnel était évidemment
légitime par contre savoir le niveau de
rémunération moyen d'autant plus quand
on entrave des facto la liberté des
Français qui eux doivent travailler je
pense que c'est légitime sur les
bénéfices de total c'est x 2 en un an
bénéfice net de 5,7 milliards de dollars
au deuxième semestre il y a du grain
moudre oui mais c'est ce que j'ai dit
c'est-à-dire qu'encore une fois moi je
considère qu'à partir du moment où il y
a des bénéfices exceptionnels ces
bénéfices doivent pouvoir être
redistribués à la fois aux Français
directement c'est à dire la question du
pouvoir d'achat c'est notamment la
remise carburant à la pompe c'est un
engagement de 500 millions d'euros de la
part de totale qu'on a obtenu qu'on est
allé chercher et qu'on a demandé et
exiger de la part de Total
descendent dans la rue à la peine
notamment de la nupesse ce week-end on
verra si les Français descendent dans la
rue et combien d'entre eux
qui s'installe dans le temps dans la
durée non parce qu'aujourd'hui je n'en
vois pas les prémices je crois qu'au
contraire les mesures que nous nous
avons prises de protection du pouvoir
d'achat qui sont exceptionnels faut
qu'on a le taux d'inflation le plus bas
d'Europe aujourd'hui de manière très
claire elles sont des choses qui sont
incontestables ça veut pas dire que
l'inflation elle est pas déjà trop
importante pour beaucoup de Français
mais ça veut dire quand même que les
mesures que nous avons prises sont des
mesures ce sont des mesures de
protection ils sont des mesures qu'on
entend prolonger notamment le bouclier
tarifaire qui en est la meilleure
illustration si on ne continuait pas en
2023 le bouclier tarifaire c'était plus
120% d'augmentation on va limiter à plus
qu'un pourcents ce qui est déjà encore
une fois beaucoup pour un certain nombre
de nos compatriotes d'où le chèque
énergie qu'on met en place pour les
populations
non seulement c'est important mais
surtout on le maintient et on protège
encore plus les populations qui sont
évidemment les plus vulnérables alors ça
c'est dans le projet de loi de finance
2023 qui est en débat à l'Assemblée
depuis cet après-midi le 49-3 ne fait
plus de doute les oppositions ont ne
voterait pas ce budget elles sont donc
toutes contre vous et si c'était vous
finalement qui aviez tort
déjà elles sont peut-être toutes contre
nous sur le budget mais elles ne disent
pas la même chose sur ce qu'elle
voudrait de ce budget donc déjà c'est
une vraie question c'est à dire qu'à un
moment si ça n'était pas le nôtre lequel
devrait être adopté le budget proposé
par les budget proposé par les fils le
budget proposé par l'URL mais ce qui
peuvent se rejoindre contre nous mais il
ne se rejoignent pas forcément pour un
projet alternatif donc à un moment c'est
aussi cette question là qui devrait être
posée et ensuite encore une fois on le
sait numériquement à l'Assemblée
nationale si toutes les oppositions se
coalisent alors ça veut dire que nous ne
sommes pas majoritaires ça je crois que
c'est un fait assez basiquement établi
et donc ça veut dire à un moment qu'en
effet les oppositions nous invitent et
nous disent qu'on n'a pas d'autre choix
d'utiliser le cas donc ce serait leur
faute vous le renvoyer la balle en tout
cas en tout cas en terme de
responsabilité oui il y a des
oppositions qui auraient pu avoir une
autre attitude pas forcément de voter en
faveur du budget considérant que voter
pour le budget c'est des facto données
insatisfaits site au gouvernement ou
valider une politique mais dire comme
nous sommes une opposition raisonnable
responsable pour autant on va pas voter
contre on va s'abstenir on particip sera
pas votre chat c'est un autre là j'ai
envoyé en républicain ou à d'autres
pourquoi pas aux parties socialiste
pourquoi pas celles et ceux qui en
permanence parlent de responsabilité et
puis leur envoyer la balle encore une
fois sur ce qu'il propose concrètement
c'est à dire que les mêmes qui nous
demandent en permanence de la réduction
de la dépense publique sont les premiers
dans le cadre de l'examen de ce texte à
nous demander des dépenses qui sont des
dépenses que vous n'avez pas réussi à
les convaincre sachant qu'elles ont eu
envie d'être convaincu vos est-ce qu'il
faut aller au bout des débats ou est-ce
qu'il faut couper court au bout d'un
moment s'il y a des amendements trop
coûteux qui sont votés est-ce qu'à un
moment il faut dire bon stop on va pas
au bout de la discussion du budget on
dégaine le 49 je crois que ça dépend de
la nature des débats profondément c'est
à dire que c'est pas la même chose si
vous avez une opposition et si vous avez
une obstruction c'est pas la même chose
c'est de manière systématique vous avez
en permanence les mêmes sujets qui
reviennent et vous voyez que vous
tournez en rond vous êtes dans l’incape
3000 abonnements il y a une inflation
très forte par rapport à l'année
dernière donc inflation obstruction
enfin j'attends de voir parce que là on
est au début de la discussion n'a pas
encore commencé le travail sur les
amendements donc sur le fond du texte on
commencera ce travail à partir de demain
qui déposent 1200 amendements c'est
l'obstruction c'est quoi c'est de la
discussion parlementaire normale pour
vous c'est l'heure liberté de façon
droit c'est un droit d'amendement
individuel donc ils peuvent en déposer
autant qu'ils le souhaitent la question
c'est qu'elle le message politique
qu'ils envoient quel message politique
que les allers envoient quand ils disent
qu'ils sont contre par exemple une
réduction d'impôts pour les entreprises
nous on veut supprimer la CV c'est un
engagement qu'on a pris pendant la
campagne présidentielle et législatives
aujourd'hui la droite en tout cas
l'Assemblée nationale nous dit qu'elle
ne souhaite pas finalement qu'on tienne
cet engagement de réduction de l'impôt
pour les entreprises donc on voit bien
qu'à un moment et on l'a vu notamment
dans la commission des finances qui a
examiné déjà ce texte c'est que le
principal gain de l'opposition c'est de
dire nous arrivons à faire battre la
majorité nous arrivons à faire battre le
gouverne mais au prix de la cause il y a
un abonnement qui retient on veut
d'ailleurs c'est pas parce que vous
utilisez le 49-3 que pour autant vous
l'adoption d'amendement
qui auront été votés avant l'utilisation
éventuelle du 49-3 vous les conserverez
tous certains ça dépend ça dépend
complètement des amendements déjà parce
qu'on a une ligne très claire sur la
question de la dépense publique et
qu'encore une fois on ne sortira pas de
ce projet de loi de finance avec un
déficit public qui sera à plus de 5%. ça
on l'a dit de manière très claire de la
même manière qu'on acceptera pas une
augmentation des impôts qui pèserait sur
les Français ou qui pèseraient sur les
entreprises ça c'est des lignes rouges
très claires
contre la vie du gouvernement vous
pourriez les conserver à la fois des
amendements qui pourraient voter mais y
compris vous le savez si jamais on
devait utiliser le gouvernement devait
utiliser le 49-3 avant la fin de
l'examen de ce texte ça n'empêche pas
que nous puissions à la fin avoir un
texte qui soit quand même enrichi des
propositions qui n'auraient pas encore
été
en tout cas je je suis lucide je sais
qu'à partir du moment toutes les
oppositions votre
elle laisse peu de place mais ça veut
dire débat sur les amendements qui
n'auraient pas été débattus voté dans
l'hémicycle vous pourriez en garder
certains de l'opposition oui donc ça
n'efface pas tous les abonnements le
travail de l'opposition et le travail
plataire un amendement à propos un
amendement pour réformer le droit des
succession vous allez le défendre oui
c'est ce que c'est l'engagement qu'on a
pris avec Mathieu Lefeuvre c'est tout
simplement de dire que on sait qu'on a
pas les moyens budgétaires en 2023 pour
les raisons que j'évoquais de dépenses
publiques de dettes publiques de pouvoir
adopter cette disposition par contre
mais il sera pas vraiment examiné ni
adopté non c'est pas grave
je sais bien mais c'est un exercice qui
arrive régulièrement dans le débat
parlementaire de préempter des débats
parce que c'est aussi ça qui sert la vie
parlementaire c'est de présenter des
débats et de garantir que l'engagement
que nous avons pris pendant la campagne
présidentielle réaffirmée dans nos
campagnes législatives sera tenue dans
ce quinquennat
que la question des droits de succession
à l'intéresse beaucoup de Français mais
pas toute votre majorité mais qui
veulent si parce que là-dessus il y a
aucune ambiguïté sur le fait que la
majorité souhaite qu'encore une fois les
engagements que nous avons pris pendant
la campagne présidentielle et nos
campagnes légitives soit tenues mais
alors l'amendement des républicains sur
les droits de succession qui reprend
exactement mot pour mot à la virgule
près ce que vous vous avez écrit vous le
voterez pas parce que on l'a expliqué
mais je peux leur expliquer une nouvelle
fois c'est qu'encore une fois on veut
queier se débat qui est cet engagement
clair qui soit réaffirmé et de la
majorité présidentielle et du
gouvernement de dire oui ce sera fait
dans ce mandat mais non on a en effet
pas les moyens budgétaires de le faire
dès ce projet de loi de finance par
contre oui on assume d'avoir ouvert ce
débat alors un modèle 3 minutes Édouard
Philippe qui propose de décaler l'âge à
65 66 voire même 67 ans est-ce que le
vrai réformateur c'est pas lui en tout
cas nous ce qu'on a clairement dit ce
que je réaffirme c'est que notre projet
c'est ni 66 67 ans notre projet c'est de
dire qu'on n'a pas d'autre choix que de
faire la réforme des retraites que c'est
une nécessité qu'on l'amènera que nous
nous avons parlé d'un report de l'âge
légal à 65 ans que c'est la base des
discussions et des concertations avec
les partenaires sociaux et que le
corollaire c'est la question de l'emploi
des seniors c'est la question des
carrières longues c'est la question
aussi du minimum de retraite que l'on
doit aux Français qui ont travaillé tout
au long de leur vie et c'est ça qu'on va
mettre en place
vous avez été augmenté je sais pas si
vous avez pu constater ça l'indemnité
qui a été versé au député et sénateur a
été revu à la hausse plus
250 euros brut par mois depuis le mois
de juillet est-ce que vous considérez
que cette hausse est justifiée continue
du contexte c'est une hausse qui a été
justifiée parce que nous avons nous
sommes adossés l'Assemblée nationale
s'est adossée sur ce qui a été fait pour
les agents de la fonction publique
c'est-à-dire qu'on a pris exactement la
même chose que les agents de la fonction
publique donc plus 3,5% au regard de
l'inflation François Ruffin s'étonne et
dit qu'il y a trois mois l'indexation
des salaires sur l'inflation a été
refusé les salaires sur l'inflation
sinon
6,2% là c'est plus 3,5% qui est comme
les agents
de la part de François Ruffin qui peut
aussi le souhaitent renoncer à son
indemnité parlementaire évidemment une
dernière question
IVG vous voulez inscrire le droit à
l'avortement dans la Constitution est-ce
que vous avez une date pour le dépôt de
votre proposition de loi puisque nous
vous le savez la première niche
parlementaire donc prend une droite
d'inscription pour mon groupe c'est la
semaine du 28 novembre donc ce sera à
l'examen la semaine du 28 novembre j'ai
toujours dit que ce serait dans le cadre
de la première niche parlementaire que
nous aurions allez une question bonus
sur un prix
nobelo vous avez vu elle a reçu le prix
Nobel de littérature c'est l'écrivaine
qui a été récompensé ou la citoyenne
engagée aux côtés de laupes selon vous
je crois que Nobel ne récompense pas les
idées politiques là pour récompenser la
qualité et le travail littéraire et
l'oeuvre littéraire et on peut ne pas
partager ces idées politiques ce qui est
mon cas mais partager les combats qui
ont été les siens notamment sur
l'agression des droits des femmes je
pense notamment l'événement qui a été
adapté récemment qui avait aussi
rencontré un grand succès populaire au
cinéma et tant mieux et récompenser
aussi l'auteur qu'elle est et on a le
droit d'avoir un avis différent sur les
idées politiques mais de saluer les
combats d'une femme et de saluer
l'auteur qu'elle est les violences
sexuelles et conjugales on y reviendra
tout à l'heure avec extrait d'ailleurs
dans quelques instants merci infiniment
brigitte c'est passé très vite avec tous
les deux Steve Jourdain on rejoint
Vincent roux en direct du figarolive
bonjour Vincent merci d'être avec nous
ce soir une première question
d'actualité Aurore berger on vous écoute
oui Aurore berger je pense que ça vous a
pas échappé il y a une élection à la
tête des républicains alors est-ce que
si
comme ça se profile actuellement le
nouveau président des républicains sera
aura un profil assez droitier s'il y a
une hémorragie d'un certain nombre de
cadres vous les accueillerez à bras
ouverts avec vos alliés d'horizon par
exemple
je sais pas s'il y a une ligne qui est
si différente que ça honnêtement entre
Bruno Retailleau et Eric Ciotti j'avoue
que la ligne de partage politique entre
les deux n'est pas si évidente que ça il
y a quelques différences je pense pas
qu'elle soit si fondamentale que ça
créerait demain ou justifierait une
hémorragie après encore une fois on a un
certain nombre de parlementaires et là
je pense à Robin Reda je pense à
Constance le griffe je pense à Eric
woert qui nous ont rejoint dès la
campagne présidentielle si d'autres
souhaitent nous rejoindre parce qu'ils
souhaitent aussi partager les combats
qui sont les nôtres ils seront
évidemment les bienvenus au sein de
renaissance mais est-ce que vous espérez
que ce soit Bruno Retailleau ou
erikiotti qui soit élu est-ce que vous
espérez qu'il y ait un départ en masse
et qui se rallie à vous parce que ça
pourrait étoffer votre majorité quand
même je crois que le principal enjeu
qu'on est et en tout cas moi celui que
j'ai en tant que présidente de groupe
c'est de garantir qu'on puisse avoir des
textes qui puisse être adoptés et
adopter ces textes c'est permettre aussi
que des majorités qui puissent exister
qui soient différentes parfois en
fonction des textes donc le sujet n'est
pas tant de se dire est-ce qu'on fait du
débauchage individuel de tel ou telle
parlementaire que de se dire est-ce
qu'on arrive à convaincre et ce qu'on
arrive à réussir à des compromis sur ces
textes-là je trouve ça c'est parfois
plus exigeant d'elle et chercher du
compromis je trouve ça plus sain en tout
cas en démocratie et encore une fois si
on a des députés à l'air qui veulent
nous rejoindre à partir du moment ils
partagent les idées et on sait qu'on a
un certain nombre d'entre eux qui sont
pas s'éloignés que ça quand même de ce
que nous défendons qui parfois même dans
leur campagne législatives ont défendu
l'idée d'être une droite très
constructive avec la majorité ils seront
évidemment les bienvenus merci Vincent à
tout à l'heure dans l'émission Yves réa
a pris place face à vous en berger vous
connaissez un des responsables de la
rédaction du Figaro Yves Thréard c'est à
VOUS bonsoir Isabelle bonsoir alors un
débat qui anime beaucoup la le personnel
politique c'est celui des violences
sexuelles et existe et aussi des
accusations qui sont portées ici ou là
contre quelques élus alors il y a eu le
cas de Monsieur Abad mais le cas de
Monsieur catenas est-ce qu'il doit
rester en poste alors qu'ils sont encore
députés l'un et l'autre
alors qu'une action de justice de
justice est lancé on est sur des cas qui
sont différents
le cas d'Adrien catenin c'est un homme
qui a reconnu des faits qui sont
constitutifs de violences conjugales
restez député il y a que lui qui peut le
dire moi je considère en tout cas qu'il
aurait fallu que son groupe politique
dans ces cas-là à partir du moment
encore une fois où il a reconnu ses
faits où ils sont donc avérés exclus ce
député est considère non pas qu'ils
doivent le renouveler je cite Jean-Luc
Mélenchon son affection parce que je
pense qu'on a peu d'affection
normalement pour un homme qui frappe sa
femme voilà je pense
que il avait désigné Adrien catenens
comme héritier politique de manière
assez évident il est peut-être très
déstabilisé par la situation politique
que ça provoque mais du coup il va à
rebours des combats qu'il a lui-même
porté des combats que sont partis
politiques apporter il va l'amitié avant
la morale oui enfin là la morale c'est
quand même un homme qui frappe sa femme
donc la question c'est jusqu'où on va
sur ces sujets là je pense sur le cas
sur le cas d'Amiens et moi ma doctrine
elle a jamais changé quel que soit les
personnes qui soient mises en cause
c'était la même chose sur Éric Coquerel
c'est je tiendrai toujours la même ligne
et c'est pareil dans le cadre Julien
Bayou qui est encore plus extravagant
honnêtement alors on va en parler
c'est de dire qu'à partir du moment où
là il y a un homme qui nie les faits qui
lui sont reprochés un homme où il y a
une information judiciaire qui est
ouverte mais pas encore de mise en
examen je ne vois pas comment vous
pouvez lui demander aujourd'hui de
démissionner de se démettre de ses
fonctions Julien Bayou
une plainte a été déposée mais ce qui
est intéressant c'est que c'est
quelqu'un qui a porté cet accusation
alors que il y avait
c'est une connaissance on va dire c'est
Madame Sandrine Rousseau qui est élu
donc Europe Écologie Les Verts et qui a
dénoncé d'une certaine façon qui a fait
œuvre de ce qu'on appelle de sycophante
de sicophante ça m'intéresse parce que
est-ce que vous trouvez ça sain que dans
un pays comme le nôtre on en soit rendu
à la dénonciation non je trouve ça
profondément dangereux je trouve ça
profondément dangereux parce qu'on est
dans une situation extravagante d'un
homme la question n'est pas qu'il soit
parlementaire ou pas d'un homme qui est
ça pourrait être une femme d'ailleurs
une personne qui est mise en accusation
de fait dont il n'a pas connaissance
dont il n'a pas les moyens de se
défendre puisque c'est une cellule
interne qui a refusé vraisemblablement
par quatre fois de l'entendre et qui en
plus au moment où Madame Rousseau s'est
exprimé n'avait même pas entendu la
victime présumée et je trouve ça
profondément dangereux ça veut dire que
moi demain ou même ce soir sur votre
plateau je peux parce que j'ai une
rivalité politique avec telle ou telle
personnalité balancer une information
sans savoir si elle est véridique sans
avoir la légitimité à le faire et je
crois encore une fois qu'elle a faim ça
ne renforce pas la protection que l'on
doit j'ai juste une petite précision à
vous demander pas trop longue parce
qu'il est très beaucoup de questions
encore la Renaissance vous recevez une
éventuelle plainte
plainte en tout cas témoignage d'une
femme qui ne veut pas que son nom soit
rendu public contre quelqu'un contre un
élu une renaissance comment vous faites
moi ce que j'ai dit et c'est pas simple
en vérité de répondre à votre question
mais ce que j'ai affirmé c'est que si
moi en tant que député et présidente de
groupe demain j'étais sollicité sur des
faits de violence qu'elle soit les
violences physiques ou des violences
sexuelles j'estime que je suis tenu et
c'est d'ailleurs ce que dit l'article du
code de procédure pénale de le signaler
au procureur de la réplique alors
qu'elle vous demande instment de ne pas
être de rester anonyme mais je ne pense
donc vous puissiez le griser ça demande
et vous faites quoi dans ces cas-là
je vois bien à quel point cette matière
là enfin et ce sujet là est complexe
complexe mais si quelqu'un vient vous
voir et vous apporte ce niveau là de
témoignage ma responsabilité c'est
évidemment d'essayer de l'accompagner et
c'est une démarche individuelle
personnelle extrêmement difficile
jusqu'à un dépôt de plainte mais je ne
peux pas le garder pour moi je ne peux
pas savoir que quelqu'un est potentiel
et donc
éventuellement ne viendra pas pouvoir
parce qu'elle sait que vous dire non
mais ça veut dire que sinon et si la
personne un potentiel agresseur vous
faites quoi
ça veut dire que vous considérer que
c'est d'abord la graisseur voilà mais on
va s'arrêter là parce que c'est un grand
débat mais c'est important de pointer
cette règle qui me paraissait encore une
fois dans un état de droit et que ça
n'est pas à moi de prononcer une peine
politique une peine médiatique mais que
la justice de le faire dans l'esprit
développé par Elisabeth
est-ce que votre féminisme à vous c'est
le même féminisme que celui de Sandrine
Rousseau
vous êtes pour un phénix est-ce que vous
trouvez que en gros le débat actuel
avec toutes les suites de Me Too ça vire
quand même
à créer une ambiance malsaine mais
surtout c'est une ambiance qui ne permet
pas à la fin encore une fois de mieux
protéger les femmes on a des dizaines
d'années de combat notamment des
associations des magistrats qui se sont
engagés pour faire en sorte que oui il y
a en effet une libération de la parole
des victimes pour que oui on ne
considère plus que tout cela était
normal que les violences sexistes du
quotidien étaient normales que les
violences sexuelles devaient être tues
donc ça c'est sain et heureusement ça
s'est libéré mais la seule voie qui
permet de mettre en termes à la
souffrance des victimes c'est la voie
judiciaire est-ce qu'elle est parfois
trop longue oui est-ce qu'elle est
difficile personnellement emprunter oui
mais c'est la seule voie qui peut
exister encore une fois dans une
démocratie alors avant de passer à la
majorité présidentielle
toute petite question vous allez me
répondre par oui ou par non est-ce que
le gouvernement ne doit pas désamorcer
le plus vite possible le conflit sur
l'essence qui sur le carburant qui a
lieu aujourd'hui alors qu'on a la
perspective d'avoir une manifestation de
16 octobre
oui ou non oui ou non la réponse est oui
mais à un moment c'est pas le
gouvernement qui peut obliger à la
signature non plus d'un accord il peut
tout faire pour accélérer les choses et
il peut encore une fois prendre les
décisions qui s'imposent de réquisition
alors Monsieur Philippe Édouard Philippe
a fait des déclarations dans la presse
ces derniers temps est-ce que vous
estimez que aujourd'hui il est d'une
certaine façon après avoir été Premier
ministre et bien un successeur potentiel
de Monsieur Macron oui il peut l'être en
2010 en 2020 il peut l'être comme
d'autres peuvent l'être et moi je crois
que notre responsabilité c'est pas dès
aujourd'hui de désigner celui ou celle
qui pourrait être le succès déjà
la vérité si on n'a pas de bilan et si
on n'a pas de résultats aucun de celles
et ceux qui espèrent être des
successeurs potentiels ne pourront
l'être le bilan c'est quoi une réforme
des retraites une réforme de la vie
est-ce que oui ou non enfin cette
perspective qui réaliste aujourd'hui
peut réussir parce que ces deux-là
qu'après toutes les autres politiques
publiques déclinent c'est la capacité
que vous avez derrière à assurer votre
modèle social à assurer son financement
à assurer le financement par exemple la
question de la dépendance de l'autonomie
de la question de la transition
énergétique dans un an
en tout cas c'est enfin un objectif
étable dans ma génération c'est
probablement la première fois qu'on se
dit que cet objectif il est atteignable
qu'on pourrait vivre dans un pays qui
culmine pas avec des taux de chômage à
plus de 10 mais qu'on peut être plutôt à
un taux de chômage à 5% et pour résiduel
c'est ça notre objectif à mon avis
principal alors on entend dans la
majorité présidentielle que il y a les
élections européennes qui vont arriver
en 2024 et qu'après ces élections
européennes et bien il faudra que cette
majorité s'organise trouve la règle du
jeu pour trouver son champion pour 2027
c'est votre avis
je pense que on a des questions qui nous
intéressent tous ici beaucoup mais qui
sont largement encore une fois
prématurés et je ne sais pas vous dire
qu'elle sera la situation économique qui
sera la nôtre en 2024 je sais ce que je
souhaite et ce que nous souhaitons
mettre en place comme réforme ce qu'on a
commencé sur l'assurance chômage qu'on
doit continuer sur les retraites qu'on
doit faire sur la question de la
formation et de la formation
professionnelle sur aussi sur les
succession sur la question de la baisse
en général des impôts et des
prélèvements obligatoires dans notre
pays soit transition énergétique je sais
ce qu'on doit faire je sais la
trajectoire qui doit être la nôtre parce
que c'est le cap qu'à un moment les
Français ont accepté qu'on fixe parce
qu'ils ont réélu le président de la
République comme le point de départ même
certains faits de l'oublier et qui lui
ont permis d'avoir malgré tout une
majorité même si elle est relative mais
une majorité à l'Assemblée nationale
donc il faut qu'on tienne ce cap après
je suis pas naïve je sais évidemment que
ces questions existent que beaucoup ont
envie qu'elles existent tout de suite je
pense que c'est trop tôt et je pense que
c'est pas du tout la réponse appropriée
à ce qu'on est en train de vivre comment
expliquer vous que la d'une part des
candidats potentiels que la presse les
médias et beaucoup d'observateurs
donnent aujourd'hui ce sont plutôt des
noms de droite c'est Monsieur Philippe
c'est Monsieur Darmanin c'est Monsieur
le Maire ça veut dire que la majorité
présidentielle et les principes elle est
majoritairement à droite aujourd'hui je
pense son action est dans ses idées
typiquement que soit Bruno Le Maire ou
Gérald Darmanin ont souhaité s'inscrire
dans une logique et celle du dépassement
politique on souhaitait s'inscrire au
sein d'un mouvement qui est celui de
renaissance et de dire que justement on
ne croit pas qu'à l'issue du quinquennat
le clivage droite-gauche doivent à
nouveau prévaloir peut-être qu'on se
trompe peut-être qu'on se trompe sur ce
sujet là mais en tout cas nous c'est la
conviction profonde qu'on a c'est que
l'écrivage qu'on a essayé de changer qui
ont des facts changé nature parce que
les Français ont souhaité qu'il change
de nature et bien encore une fois on ne
doit pas y retourner dans trois ans ou
dans quatre ans et c'est le choix que
nous avons fait en étant des députés
ce groupe là Renaissance et moi j'y
crois profondément après est-ce que
aujourd'hui ils sont par principe
quelqu'un comme Bruno Le Maire ou Gérald
Darmanin classé à droite parce qu'ils en
viennent la question c'est les mesures
que l'on met en oeuvre regardez la
question du travail Nicolas Sarkozy en
2007 il a pré-enté la question du
travail sur la gauche il parlait du mot
travailleur dans les meetings de droite
en disant qu'à un moment c'était une
valeur qu'il devait à un moment être à
nouveau incarné et aujourd'hui la droite
abandonne cette valeur là et cette
question là je crois que nous on a
réussi à préenter cette question là les
dévastes sans fin à gauche sur le droit
à la paresse qui est quand même un débat
assez un vrai semblable plutôt que la
défense justement de celles et ceux qui
travaillent et la capacité à atteindre
le plein emploi et on a une droite qui
ne s'exprime plus sur ces sujets là donc
vous le classez où dernière question
cette thématique là typiquement bah moi
je la classe typiquement dans les sujets
que nous nous avons réussi à présenter
alors de tous les noms que j'ai cités il
y en a un donc vous êtes normalement la
plus proche puisque vous avez soutenue
comme lui Alain Juppé en 2017 c'est
Édouard Philippe est-ce que vous vous
sentez plus proche d'Edouard Philippe
que des deux autres que j'ai cité moi je
travaille avec les trois et je travaille
je vais dire aussi d'autant plus il faut
être honnête avec Bruno Le Maire et
Gérald Darmanin qui sont membres du
gouvernement ils sont groupes membres du
parti politique auquel j'ai fait le
choix d'adhérer en vérité vous avez
aujourd'hui trois candidats potentiels
vous savez quoi tant mieux et moi je
préfère qu'on évite d'avoir un jeu à
somnule qui fasse qu'à force de essayer
de torpiller la candidature de l'un ou
de l'autre on se retrouve un an ou
quelques mois avant la présidentielle en
se disant qu'aucun des trois ne serait
en situation d'être candidat je préfère
en avoir un peu trop
identifier des Français qui sont jugés
par tout le monde légitime comme pouvant
être demain candidat à la présidentielle
que se retrouver dans la situation
d'autres partis politiques qui en ont
pas un seul
républicain notamment alors dernière
question toute petite vous en avez parlé
tout à l'heure les droits de succession
vous a accusé en mettant ce dossier sur
la table de jouer en solo mais c'est une
proposition qu'on a porté pendant la
campagne présidentielle alors pourquoi
c'est pas ou quand vous accusez ça ça
venait ça venait pas des oppositions ça
venait de votre groupe chacun après 10
qu'il veut dire et chacun est libre de
le croire moi ce que je sais c'est que
dès les premiers instants de discussion
sur ce que devait être ce projet de loi
de finance j'ai mis sur le sujet sur la
table avec un certain nombre d'autres
députés du groupe en disant nous ne
devons pas abandonner cette question là
de la baisse de l'impôt on le fait pour
les entreprises on le fait sur la fin de
la taxe d'habitation et on doit
absolument démontrer que dans ce mandat
on fera aussi la baisse des impôts de
succession merci merci beaucoup Yves
tiens à propos de proposition de loi qui
font question il y a une proposition qui
consiste à
demander à ce que l'abandon de poste ne
donne plus droit à des allocations
chômage la majorité en a parlé pas
seulement elle est bien sûr vous l'avez
voté en expliquant que il y avait une
explosion de cas Orsana jamais été
documenté il n'y a aucune statistique
qui prouve que effectivement c'est un
phénomène qui augmente en fait les DRH
les plus qualifiées disent que ça n'est
pas le cas alors on a aujourd'hui est-ce
que c'est pas un peu démago et pour
faire plaisir à la droite que vous
faites non parce que d'abord c'est une
remontée qu'on a eu sur tous nos
territoires en tant que parlementale le
chef d'entreprise qui sont souvent des
entreprises de petites entreprises de
TPE PME notamment hôtellerie
restauration qui nous disent des facto
est-ce que c'est le poste covid ou pas
je ne sais pas l'expliquer mais en tout
cas qu'il y a une recrudescence de plus
en plus importante de ce phénomène
n'abandon de poste et qui nous le disent
dans toutes nos circonscriptions ça
n'est pas documenté on a cherché les
statistiques et avec la meilleure bonne
foi possible ça n'a pas été établie un
député de mon groupe qui n'a pas eu
plusieurs chefs d'entreprise qui lui ont
dit ça et ce qui est inéquitable c'est
de se dire que la personne qui
démissionne finalement est moins
protégée que la personne qui abandonne
son poste et qui ne donne plus signe de
vie à son employeur du jour au lendemain
et la salarié la salariés qui est
harcelé dans son entreprise
de partir
valoir si ça c'est ce qu'on a c'est ce
qu'on a mis dans la loi c'est ce qu'on a
mis dans la loi justement c'est que on a
protégé la possibilité évidemment de
l'abandon de poste quand il y a un
risque pour la santé évidemment de
l'employé y compris évidemment dans des
cas extrêmes que vous évoquez de risque
de harcèlement par contre c'est pas
normal de mieux protéger celui qui du
jour au lendemain donne plus une vie à
son chef d'entreprise ne revient plus du
tout travailler versus celui qui a
l'honnêteté l'intégrité tout simplement
de démissionner pour aller c'est pas un
recul des droits est-ce que vous n'avez
pas voté un recul non au contraire je
pense que c'est une protection qu'on a
maintenu pour celles et ceux qui les
employeurs qu'on a qui n'ont pas d'autre
choix que d'abandonner leur poste pour
des questions de santé mais qui se
justifient encore une fois parce qu'il
n'est pas normal que celui qui abandonne
le poste soit mieux protégé que celui
qui allait être démissionné bonjour
evaas merci beaucoup d'être avec nos
députés européens et écologie les Verts
porte-pa
[Musique]
vous aider sur le premier sujet la
baisse de l'impôt sur les entreprises je
l'ai évoqué c'est un engagement que nous
avons pris et c'est un engagement que
nous tiendrons de considérer qu'en effet
on a aujourd'hui un taux de prélèvement
obligatoire dans notre pays même si on
la réduit dans le précédent quinquennat
qui est toujours trop élevé et que c'est
un enjeu d'être activité ensuite sur le
chiffre que vous évoquez sur les 63
milliardaires et sur l'empreinte carbone
c'est faux c'est faux parce que dans ce
chiffre là vous comptez toutes les
entreprises qu'ils ont donc ça veut dire
que l'émission carbone qui est faite par
LVMH pour en citer une est attribuée à
son propriétaire donc il faudrait pas
croire que les 63 déplacements
individuels par exemple de ces 63
personnes que vous évoquez provoquent
50% de nos émissions c'est les
entreprises dont ils sont actionnaires
dont ils sont propriétaires ce qui n'est
pas tout à fait la même chose donc je
pense qu'il faut avoir l'honnêteté de
présenter le débat c'est le patron
ça veut dire en fait ce dont ils sont
actionnaires absolument et c'est
exactement ça que
sur la fortune c'est les portefeuilles
de placement donc c'est tout à fait
adéquat de prendre cet exemple là non
parce que la manière avec laquelle vous
le présentez quand vous dites x
milliardaire réalise X et missions de
carbone on a l'impression que c'est dans
leur comportement individuels
des entreprises c'est juste et c'est
comment
on fait en sorte en effet de décarboner
nos industries de décarboner nos
entreprises c'est ça la question qui
doit en effet nous préoccuper et c'est
aussi quels sont les propositions que
nous on porte typiquement sur la
question du logement qui est là vous le
savez comme moi évidemment l'un des
enjeux majeurs si on veut réduire notre
empreinte carbone c'est notamment la
question du logement bien nous allons
nous porter dans le cadre du débat que
nous allons avoir dans quelques heures
maintenant et bien la réorganisation
dispositif importante les dispositifs
pinels par exemple dispositif PTZ pour
faire en sorte que ces dispositifs
soient réorientés uniquement vers du
logement des carbonés et ça c'est à la
fois un gain pour nos finances publiques
environ 2 milliards pour nos fin grand
public et c'est aussi dire très
clairement si vous voulez avoir des
avantages fiscaux liés justement à la
construction et bien ça doit être
réorienté de manière très claire et très
nette vers de la description
qu'est-ce qui vous gêne dans l'ISF
climatique ce qui me gêne c'est que
encore une fois l'ISF n'a pas fait ça de
la démonstration de son efficacité au
contraire nous n'avons pas eu grâce à
l'ISF plus d'attractivité c'est
l'inverse qui s'est produit
à la solidarité c'est le premier enjeu
le deuxième c'est de responsabiliser les
plus riches sur leur patrimoine c'est
exactement l'enjeu de l'ISF climatique
parce que là où ils investissent ils ont
une empreinte carbone selon qu'ils
investissent dans des projets qui sont
bons pour la transition écologique ou au
contraire qui sont néfastes pour le
climat il faut responsabiliser les plus
riches là-dessus et vous refusez de le
faire et chaque fois qu'on propose une
mesure en fait qui touche les plus
aisées vous refusez d'agir vous avez
toujours une façon de noyer le poisson
et d'essayer de ramener le sujet sur un
sur autre chose mais moi je dis que là
il faut que tout le monde contribue à
l'effort climatique a commencé par les
plus aisés parce qu'ils ont une
responsabilité au travers de leur
patrimoine mais moi j'ai pas de
difficulté sur la responsabilisation qui
doit pouvoir exister
je dis juste de manière très claire que
nous ne serons pas la majorité qui
augmentera les impôts parce que c'est
une ligne rouge très nette que nous
avons fixée et qui a été validé
d'ailleurs par les Français sinon il
n'aurait pas élu le président de la
République qui a tenu très clairement et
très nettement cette ligne là pendant la
campagne présidentielle les Français ont
élu le président de la République pour
faire barrage l'extrême droite j'ai voté
manuel Macron en ce je crois qu'ils
l'ont placé nette du premier valoir de
ce vote de second tour pour appliquer un
projet qui n'est pas celui que veulent
les Français non je crois qu'au
contraire ils veulent que les plus
contribuent le plus aux dérèglement
climatique parce que ce sont ceux qui
émettent le plus contre le dérèglement
climatique vous avez une autre
proposition evasas oui
l'autre sujet c'était le plan de
sobriété j'ai regardé votre plan de
sobriété très intéressante bien sûr il
faut baisser le chauffage réduire
effectivement les enseignes les
enseignes la nuit on est tout à fait
d'accord avec ces propositions là mais
est-ce que vous ne croyez pas que le
principal enjeu en fait pour la sobriété
c'est bien la rénovation thermique des
logements or quand je regarde votre
budget ou le budget de votre
gouvernement et bien il ne met que 2,5
milliards d'euros sur la table pour la
rénovation des logements alors que le
rapport Sichel que le gouvernement
lui-même a commandé a dit très
clairement qu'il fallait 9,3 milliards
d'euros par an pour traiter les
passoires thermiques en disant donc vous
avez les chiffres vous savez combien il
faut mettre et vous refuser de mettre
les moyens nécessaires alors que la
meilleure moyen de faire de la sobriété
et de réduire la consommation d'énergie
c'est bien sûr d'isoler les logements et
bien au contraire vous laissez les
ménages seuls face à la flambée des prix
de l'énergie et c'est eux qui m'ont payé
le plus le prix fort cet hiver quand il
va y avoir une consommation d'énergie
élevée et des prix d'électricité qui
augmente de 15% et donc vous proposez un
bouclier tarifaire alors nous nous avons
plusieurs propositions mais la première
position c'est de mettre 9 milliards
d'euros sur la table pour les passeurs
thermiques on a aussi une proposition de
vos clients
progressif pour protéger mieux les plus
modestes et d'avoir un tarif libre
au-delà pour décourager les
surconsommation mais moi le premier
enjeu de ce budget c'est vraiment le
plan Marshall pour la rénovation
terminée
de l'État c'est ce qu'on fait notamment
et c'est ce qu'on a engagé avec le plan
de relance c'est-à-dire comment on fait
en sorte justement que toutes ces enjeux
de rénovation thermique ce soit d'abord
l'État et les collectivités locales qui
en face la démonstration donc ça un
tiers du plan de relance a été fléchée
vers des enjeux qui sont justement des
enjeux énergétiques et de rénovation
thermique c'est ce qu'on fait aussi avec
le fond vert 1,5 milliards pour les
collectivités local donc c'est
directement la rénovation demain de nos
écoles de nos gymnases de nos centres de
loisirs ensuite c'est évidemment
accompagner les ménages notamment les
plus modestes c'est ce qu'on fait avec
ma prime rénov par exemple car un enjeu
essentiel de comment on fait suffisant
franchement on va encore la renforcer
dans ce budget donc ça veut dire oui 1
on a quand même des milliers de Français
qui ont pu en bénéficier il faut le
faciliter on veut par exemple intégrer
ce dispositif dans ce qu'on appelle les
maisons France service c'est à dire
c'est porte d'entrée qui font que vous
avez toutes les administrations de
l'État qui sont à côté de chez vous et
qui peuvent vous accompagner parce qu'il
y a beaucoup de Français aujourd'hui qui
pourraient en bénéficier qui ne savent
pas en fait comment appréhender ce
dispositif comment ça fonctionne
concrètement mais c'est accompagner les
ménages évidemment les plus fragiles
mais
côté même le gouvernement l'a dit ça a
manqué sa cible du point de vue des
rénovations globales puisqu'il n'y a que
2500 rénovations globale on voit bien
qu'on n'est pas du tout à la hauteur de
l'enjeu une rénovation globale tout le
monde je sais quand on fait des travaux
chez soi c'est 30000 euros or
aujourd'hui ma prime rénov c'est en
moyenne 3000 euros donc que voulez-vous
que les Français fassent avec 3000 euros
ils peuvent pas faire une rénovation
globale les enjeux financiers on les
connaît soit on met les moyens soit on
ne dit pas qu'on fait quelque chose qui
a une volonté politique quand même
suffisante pour que les passoires
thermiques des particuliers soit vite
réparées là où je vous rejoins parce que
c'est des éléments factuels c'est qu'en
effet l'un des premiers chantiers qu'on
a si on veut réduire massivement
l'empreinte carbone c'est en effet
clairement la question du logement et la
question de la rénovation thermique en
plus cette double peine et écologique et
économique pour un certain nombre de
Français donc là dessus je suis
évidemment et je ne peux qu'être
d'accord après je persiste ta pensée que
ma prime rénove est un bon dispositif
qu'il faut qu'il soit plus lisible plus
simple à comprendre qu'il faut qu'en
fait on aille vers les Français qui sont
directement concernés pour garantir
qu'il l'utilisent parce que c'est
souvent ça dans les difficultés qu'on a
sur les aides qu'on met en place que
l'État met en place quelle qu'elle soit
d'ailleurs c'est faire en sorte que
celles et ceux qui en ont le plus besoin
en bénéficient donc c'est élargir au
maximum ce dispositif c'est ce qu'on
fait on renforce financièrement
budgétairement encore ce dispositif et
après c'est les dispositions qu'on prend
sur le parc de l'État mais 1,5 milliards
juste pour en plus de tout ce qu'on fait
pour les collectivités uniquement sur la
rénovation demain de nos écoles nos
centres de loisirs de nos gymnase c'est
pas tout à fait mince comme soutien
sachant qu'on veut réorienter en plus
tous les dispositifs de soutien à
l'investissement des collectivités de
manière à ce que ça d'abord vers les
questions par exemple d'éclairage public
des choses très concrètes mais qui ont
un impact sur le climat qui évidemment
déterminant et bah ça le fond vert pour
le climat en 2023 c'est 375 millions
d'euros c'est 1,5 milliards sur
plusieurs années donc déjà on n'est pas
du tout à la hauteur de l'enjeu y
compris pour la rénovation vous parlez
des bâtiments scolaires ça a été chiffré
également pour rénover les bâtiments
scolaires il faudrait 4 milliards
d'euros par an sur 10 ans donc là aussi
on est très très loin du compte et sur
ma prime rénov oui c'est un bon
dispositif tout à fait je vais vous dire
c'est même mieux que le site le crédit
d'impôt qui existait auparavant mais il
y a un enjeu d'accompagnement je vais
être d'accord avec vous aussi c'est vrai
qu'il faut renforcer l'accompagnement
pour guider les ménages mais il y a un
ange financier vous ne pouvez pas le
nier tant que vous refuserez de mettre
les les montants qui sont nécessaires
pour les rénovations globales on
arrivera pas à réduire les passoires
thermiques il y a 4,8 millions de
passoires thermiques 4,8 millions de
ménage qui ont un logement avec une
étiquette FG et qui est cet hiver vont
avoir de grandes qui veulent dire quoi
c'est les étiquettes énergétiques après
un diagnostic énergétique c'est ce c'est
les ce qui est consomment le plus
d'énergie ce qu'on a interdit d'ailleurs
dans le loi climat résilience de pouvoir
être mis à la location si jamais
justement les rénovations n'étaient pas
faites sur les montants sur les montants
dans le fond vous êtes assez convaincus
parce que non mais vous pourriez faire
mieux vous l'avez dit d'accord mais il
faut nous dire dans là comme on le
finance absolument c'est la deuxième
question non non mais sa deuxième
question revient la première question
Quels sont les dépenses publiques que
l'on coupe parce qu'à un moment il y a
aussi la réduction de la dépense après
ce sont des arbitrages réduction des
arbitres
en place l'ISF climatiques donc on
augmente les impôts alors tout à l'heure
en verger disait que les oppositions on
avait semble-t-il pas du tout envie
d'être convaincu quoi qu'il en soit par
le budget et que vous seriez donc obligé
de dégainer à 49-3 c'est ce que vous
disiez ce que c'est votre sentiment en
fait ce sont les oppositions qui
poussent le gouvernement à passer en
force alors là notre passage en force
parce qu'on utiliserait le 49-3 c'est
pas un outil qu'on aurait créé ou
inventé dans ce quinquennat nous avons
participé au dialogue de Bercy nous y
sommes allés de bonne foi nous avons
porté des propositions celles que je
vous fais là nous avons déposé 162
amendements qui sont passés en
commission nous avons défendu toutes les
options et on a un mur devant nous parce
qu'en fait un vérité une évolution rien
donc on est forcé de constater que de
toute façon on ne peut pas avancer mais
nous nous rêvons en fait d'un
gouvernement qui prennent conscience
qu'on est plus vraiment dans la
Cinquième République et qu'il y a une
sixième république qui vient de faire
irruption en fait dans ce Parlement et
qu'ils prennent conscience qu'il y a une
forme de proportionnelle et qui doit
composer en fait avec les différents
groupes et aujourd'hui il le fait pas du
tout il n'y a aucun amendement qui
accepté par exemple en commission ça
prouve bien qu'il n'y a aucune volonté
de co-construire ce budget moi je suis
pas du tout inquiète sur le fait qu'à la
fin vous le verrez sur le texte final on
aura des amendements des oppositions qui
auront été acceptés 49-3 ou pas on
pourra se revoir à ce moment-là et je
pense que vous pourrez en faire le
constat avec moi parce que ça a été le
cas quand on a examiné le texte pouvoir
d'achat ou le projet de loi de
financement rectificatif de cet été
après j'ai envie de vous retourner la
question c'est à dire que si on accède à
toutes les demandes de repécologie les
Var que ce soit donc sur l'augmentation
des impôts sur la réduction là le refus
de en fonction de certains impôts sur la
hausse de la dépense publique ce qui est
très présent décalage avec ce qu'on a
nous proposer aux Français je ne vois
pas où est la majorité pour vos tests
est-ce que vous me garantissez que la
France insoumise votre eltexte c'est la
société
non mais si j'accédais c'est créer des
coalitions
à toutes les demandes qui sont formulées
aujourd'hui par Europe Écologie Les
Verts c'est à dire des facto quand même
plus de dépenses publiques et aussi plus
d'impôts oui c'est le choix que vous
faites politique que vous assumez est-ce
que vous me dites sur ce plateau que
elle est file votre aie que le Parti
communiste le vautrait que les sociaux
c'est à dire votre intergroupe ne pèse
le votre S qui garantirait peut-être une
maladie pas du tout de travailler avec
un seul groupe mais avec plusieurs
groupes au créer des conséquences de
différents groupes ne disent pas la même
chose sauf que ce que vous me disiez que
ce que dit la nuit pèse et qui vaut
est-ce que dit les LR et qui vaut est-ce
que il y a des majorités qui peuvent
être trouvées dans l'assemblée et moi je
arrive à fonctionner avec des parlements
la proportionnelle oui créer des
coalitions
tous regardez bien si et voilà on est en
fait une dernière exception un peu un
dinosaure de l'Europe et en vérité il va
falloir qu'on change de culture et qu'on
arrive à co-construire des choses
ensemble mais visiblement ce
gouvernement n'a pas du tout compris
qu'on était dans une nouvelle ère
démocratique merci beaucoup Eva ça
d'avoir accepté ce débat avec Robert
berger est-ce que Vincent roux est avec
nous en direct du Figaro live Vincent
vous avez encore une question merci une
autre question d'actualité pour Aurore
berger merci
j'arrive à remettre mon oreillette
bonsoir bonsoir rebonsoir Aurore berger
Emmanuel Macron promet ce soir
d'accroître aujourd'hui d'accroître
l'aide militaire à l'Ukraine question
tout simple est-ce qu'on peut
aujourd'hui encore se le permettre on a
livré
prélever sur nos sur nos stocks 18
canons César on a un certain nombre de
papiers qui documente le fait que
l'armée française est à l'os en termes
de capacité
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on peut
encore promettre aux Ukrainiens est-ce
qu'on leur promet pas la lune en disant
qu'on ne va pas mettre de la militaire
ou bien est-ce qu'on n'est pas en danger
maintenant notre appareil sur
l'affaiblissement de la désarmées je
crois qu'on doit le faire déjà on est
les premiers à avoir tenu une loi de
programmation militaire et avoir non
seulement voté des crédits qui étaient
largement en hausse et qui vont
continuer cette année à être en hausse
mais surtout ne pas avoir relié au fur
et à mesure des années
très claire les moyens de nos armées et
qu'on a pas varié sur cette ligne là
dans le mandat après sur la question sur
l'Ukraine mais l'importance orbergé
c'est d'avoir des moyens suffisants
c'est pas d'accroître c'est d'avoir les
moyens suffisant c'est ce que disent
tous les rapports notamment les rapports
de l'OTAN mais pour encore une fois
avoir les moyens suffisants encore
fallait-il faire le choix budgétaire de
les augmenter les augmenter très
nettement ce qu'on a fait dans le
précédent quinquennat est-ce qu'on va
continuer à faire dans ce cas quand tenu
du repas voilà nous sommes à l'os dans
l'armée française nous avons donné le
maximum et on est obligé de ponctionner
des commandes danoises pour pouvoir
aider les Ukrainiens comment on fait
pour faire plus mais sans affaiblir
encore davantage nos armées
en renforçant aujourd'hui la résistance
Ukraine c'est factuelle je pense que
c'est une nécessité que nous avons
n'oubliez pas que au tout début de cette
annexion de cette tentative d'annexion
et de guerre de la Russie à l'Ukraine
Vladimir Poutine prometex les duré
quelques semaines et que l'Ukraine
serait rayé de la carte aujourd'hui ce
qui se passe c'est la capacité de
l'Ukraine à démontrer la force de sa
résistance à être peut-être en capacité
même parce qu'on en vient à discuter de
ça de d'avoir la Crimée qui pourrait
être reprise à la Russie donc vous voyez
bien quand même le changement total de
paradigme par rapport à ce qu'on avait
au tout début de la guerre pourquoi ça a
été possible possible grâce à la
résistance ukrainienne mais possible
aussi parce que nous on n'a pas failli
et parce que les pays européens ont
solidarité ce sont engagés à la fois sur
les sanctions évidemment vis-à-vis de la
Russie qui produisent des effets mais
aussi en soutien militaire
Vincent une dernière relance oui la
question c'est que l'histoire elle est
pleine de soutien militaire qu'on a
apporté à des armées qui ont gagné mais
au détriment de nos propres outils
militaires est-ce que la question je
vous la retourne il faut pas précisément
augmenter mais vraiment considérablement
des budgets de budget militaire français
peut-être sur le modèle allemand qui met
100 milliards sur la table le budget
militaire français pour que à la fois
l'armée française et les armes
suffisantes et nécessaires et qu'on
puisse aider d'autres nations comme la
nation Ukraine une réponse brève on
arrive je crois que c'est l'engagement
qu'on va prendre dans ce budget parce
que la loi de programmation militaire à
nouveau que nous souhaitons voter c'est
une loi qui est encore en augmentation
donc ça veut dire qu'on va non pas
stabiliser les mois c'est ce qui va être
en discussion dans les semaines qui
viennent avec le ministre des armées
mais ce qui veut dire que c'est pas
juste une stabilisation de ce qu'on a
fait dans le précédent mandat qui était
déjà en hausse très net c'est à dire
qu'on va encore augmenter par rapport à
les moyens par rapport à ce qu'on a fait
dans le précédent quinquennat je crois
que ça répond à cette nécessité encore
une fois d'avoir une armée digne équipée
valorisée avec des moyens efficaces et
aussi à l'effort conjoncturel qu'on doit
continuer à faire évidemment on va
suivre alors attentivement les débats
Vincent roux sur cette question merci en
tout cas d'avoir participé à cette
émission hors berger on vous libère les
débats dans l'hémicycle maintenant pour
vous aussi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine avec
dans auditions publiques à 19h30 sur LCP
public c'est la bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]